everybody what is going on today I'm
going to be showing you guys how you can
put a computer a full computer in your
car for under $100 so what I'm going to
show you right now is all the you know
stuff that's really required for this as
well as some of the stuff that's not
necessarily required but might be fun to
have and really the only thing that I
can't show you right now because it's in
my car is one of the cables but we'll
get to that so I've got everything laid
out here so I'm just going to point the
camera down and show you what we got
going on so so here we have got the
screen here this screen is like 17
dollars or something on Amazon it's a
composite screen the Raspberry Pi model
B has a direct composite plug I'm told
that the B model B plus I want to say
was the audio cable the audio port is
also a composite port someone can
compose below and let me know I've only
done this with the model B so if you
have a model B plus you'll have to look
into that because any of the HDMI
screens are like $60 at least that's
obviously a quite quite a bit different
than like a $17 screen so so that's the
screen that we're using it does come
with like 3m tape so you could peel this
off and go stick it on your dash I
wouldn't recommend that I have been I've
been toying around with this for a while
and chances are on the first stick your
head you're not going to really know
that that's where you want it to be so
what I did is I got like a 3m tape and
velcro right so 3m velcro and with that
you can you know put it on both sides
stick it but then if you ever need to
remove it for whatever reason you sure
can so at least for me I found that the
best place for my monitor because I
guess I call this a monitor the best
place for the screen is like to the back
left on my dash and or you could also
buy one of those little fancy head units
to like that like have a screen on it
and it are like a pop-out screen those
are like 200 plus dollars and there's
some cheaper ones but they rip they like
breaks so easily so I just feel
you know let's go ahead and just have a
cheap spring and and you know forfeit
maybe seventeen dollars if it goes bad
rather than you know eighty bucks or two
hundred or whatever so anyway um throw
that as an option but anyways this just
goes on my dash and it goes you know
kind of tucked into the left hand side
but that's also where I'm feeding all of
my wires so if I ever needed to rewire
for some reason you need to be able to
remove the screen so anyway back to all
the parts now this so that's the screen
it's a composite screen um this
basically it comes and you got all these
cables you're going to need your own
composite and your own power so it
basically comes just this stuff is
connected to the screen but you'll need
to get your own power supply and all of
that if you're using a car you're going
to use their power supply though they do
have it does come with a power supply
with positive and negative lead so then
you can use that and you can connect
that to your uh the app or the trying to
think of what the proper term is for
this but there's like a specific
accessories slot for most cars and
you'll just wire that to the accessory
slot otherwise you can of course you can
wire it to just about anything you can
wire it to because the screen can you
know turn on and off with the cars
ignition no problem so you can wire it
to your cigarette lighter or you can
wire it to some people do like the
overhead light you could wire it to that
anything like that you can wire it to so
next up obviously I've got a Raspberry
Pi I do have a case this case is not a
case that everyone's going to want but
what I like about this case it's a
Raspberry Pi camera case as well and so
if you can't see that's a Raspberry Pi
camera in there and then obviously the
raspberry PI's in here so this sits on
my - the actual Raspberry Pi and when
the camera faces out on the dash so I
pretty much have a constant you know
camera on the car then so that's that
it'll be a big hit with the Russians I
don't know if y'all are familiar but
pretty much every Russian or a ton of
Russians drive around constant camera
because it's crazy over there
the next thing I have here is this USB
hub chances are you're going to have a
lot more peripherals than you think and
so like if you
have like for me I've got this Wi-Fi
adapter here so that gives me Wi-Fi and
then I've got the USB hub and then that
gives me the mouse and a keyboard now
you obviously don't need a mouse in a
keyboard and ideally you won't have
those but there might be times where you
do and so this is the keyboard I have
it's actually a flimsy keyboard right
it's a foldable keyboard so that's
really helpful for portability I had
intentions of putting that putting it on
my dashboard but my dashboard on the
dash of my car but it doesn't stick to
anything like it's a plastic and nothing
sticks to it no glue no duct tape no
nothing thickness stick to this but
that's okay you don't really need a
keyboard there ideally the computer is
just displaying stats or doing other
things for you that we'll talk about in
a minute
so that's keyboard then obviously a
wireless mouse that you can have now
let's get to the really important stuff
so my intention or you know like what
you know what might you actually use a
computer in your car for so um for me uh
one is for the camera
I wanted to have a camera and then also
put the camera on like a loop you know
so every 24 hours it just recycles stuff
so a looped camera would be cool but
also I want to plug it into my car's
onboard computer so to do that you need
an obd2 cable and you just need a USB
obd2 cable then you can plug that into
your PI and use PI obd and get your obd
stats
the other cool thing that you can think
about doing so with the obd by the way
you can get things like like your RPM
which approach you probably have on your
dash already but your rpm like throttle
position you can pick up your check
engine light codes clear those all that
kind of fun stuff there's all kinds of
stats that you can get from your car's
computer that aren't just immediately
available to you so you can get that
that's probably the main reason I got it
I like want to do the onboard computer
and then also you can do things
obviously you can record things but you
can also do things like remote start if
you have the Raspberry Pi in your car
you can connect it to your ignition and
do remote start you can also do
something as cool as like
like voice start you know like you could
literally be like cars start and the car
starts so that'd be kind of cool so my
car it's a an s2000 so I actually have a
push to start button so most of the work
for actually doing a voice start is done
for me so hopefully I'll be able to do
that and show you guys a pretty awesome
video on that as well so then finally
how do we the the main issue with
putting a Raspberry Pi in your car is
that when you turn on and off the
ignition it just cuts power immediately
and obviously that's a bad thing so how
do we overcome that and to do that we
use MCM electronics so let me do this
and I actually about like one of every
single switch they have they've got a
bunch of switches on there for the
Raspberry Pi and the idea of these
switches is you flick the switch and it
sends a signal to the your i/o pins runs
a quick little script that is basically
constantly checking for the switch
flipped and will shut down your
Raspberry Pi based on the switch so
we've got some rocker switches these two
are rocker switches this one is just if
you have your own switch and then this
one is a cool little power button I just
really liked it like glows blue so cool
but those are all only useful if you
have constants power so what do you use
if you have a car well they sell car
switches as well so as soon as I can
untangle this from this mess so this is
a car switch and this is their 3 amp car
switch so again this is the cables to
shut down and it stores this is 3 amps
so this will store 3 amps and this
connects basically to what I was
describing before you'll have this
connected to your accessory slot
basically and that way it only turns on
and off like with your car's ignition
you could also do like you could connect
it to your cigarette lighter if you
wanted like if you've already like if
you have a radar detector let's say and
you've hardwired your radar detector
your you might not have another slot so
you can you know you can connect it even
with your radar detector or you splice
into that or your cigarette lighter or
whatever so that's this and also has two
USB port so you could power like up to 2
PI's on this thing and but really you're
probably just going to power one time
but you can actually work these
and said the signals between the pines
but anyway I'm just going to use it for
one pie for now so you have this you
hardwire this that way when you turn off
the ignition
it still has power because it's three
amps and it will send the shutdown
signal to your Raspberry Pi shut it down
and your everything's good and then when
you start your car back up again it'll
start up so finally on the Raspberry Pi
itself not too many people are aware of
it but you actually can like right now
I'm at you know the command line but
obviously I have to type start X oh I
got myself lost here start why is it C
start X there we go summers I kept
hitting the space key so you can start
the desktop and actually you can
automatically start the desktop and you
can also edit your config file and auto
start anything so you can auto start all
kinds of scripts so you can start auto
start your obd script let's say and all
kinds of stuff like that so now I'm
going to go ahead and do is show you
guys in the car so this is all kind of
extra stuff I just so happen to have a
purchasing problem I actually bought two
of these screens I've got a bunch of
these switches the other good thing to
have meant to show you guys are these
things what is this this is a USB
extension cord it's 15 feet and it's
very useful because you can run that for
any same reason you might want an
extension cord you can run that through
your car and put stuff where you want it
to be so like this USB hub I really want
that kind of in the back so there's not
a bunch of cords in the front but the
computer is going to be in the front so
I'm going to run the USB cord to the
back and that's where I plan to put the
USB hub anyway it looks to me like this
is really bright to you guys it's not
that bright it's just probably the
camera to the camera but anyway yeah a
lot of really exciting things because
you can put a computer in your core and
then you've got you know like the camera
you can add the sensors and all that you
can also add like gyro sensors to the
pie and then I'll get that stuff so I
actually take my car to the track like a
road course and to get anything
comparable to this like I spent pride in
total and all this stuff plus a gyro
sensor like still like less than a
hundred dollars on all this
and to get something even close to this
- the camera well actually if we include
the camera I went over a hundred dollars
but to get something similar to that it
cost about $1000 so to do it yourself is
like way cheaper anyway plus you have a
computer in your car so you're pretty
much de-facto that one of the coolest
people on the road
so anyways now let's actually see it in
the car
alright the Raspberry Pi computer cover
so here is my car and over here that's a
blinding Sun anyway you can see now over
on the left hand side of the dash there
that's where the computer screen is let
me pop over there long that's what you
okay Missy right okay so there you can
see is the actual screen here now like I
was saying that's actually a really
cheap screen he was like eighteen
dollars screws on these it's definitely
worth it and then over here is probably
easier to see the high the yellow thing
is the USB hub and there is the PI
behind the stickers and all that I've
kind of got a hidden and tucked away um
there's a couple options there you yeah
you can put it somewhere like I'm in the
dash and hide the PI completely but the
power does get hot especially if you've
got a lot of peripherals so I thought
the best ventilation would be right on
out there but where it is really I don't
even see it you know because the
stickers are in the way it's not really
lose anything by having it up there so
let's go inside real quick so wait a
second in the pie should come on the
screen itself is actually hooked up to
the accessory slot on the fuse box so
there's all the random PI stuff so the
screen is just hooked up there and then
the pie itself is hooked up with a
switch from osburgh circuits and what
the switch does is a three amps which so
the switch itself will have like a
residual charge to it and then when you
shut down the switch itself will sense
when there's no more power coming to the
switch and it will then issue a shutdown
to the Raspberry Pi which is quite nice
that way you don't corrupt the SD card
when you
down so there's the pie and all that I
could show you um maybe some of the OBD
stuff real quick if you'd like la no one
no one gets to answer me anyways because
it doesn't really matter let's see if I
can bring this into better focus and if
you didn't notice we went straight to
desktop you can do all kinds of startup
stuff starting at the desktop is just an
option and wrasse buy options or rash
buy config rather anyway so this is like
the OBD thing it's going to pull up it's
connecting to the serial port so I've
got a obd cable it's obd2 cable
connected this is pulling data from the
cars computer as soon as it comes up so
there's a little bit data you can also
navigate the data by either your arrows
or mouse button so there we go we've got
engine rpm you've got throttle position
so I'll push in my throttle here and you
can see the throttle position is now
eighty eight point six three so that's
pretty cool um intake air temp 177
that's still pretty hot so I just
actually drove it so yeah that's a good
thing that engine rpm in miles per hour
is zero that's good to know not crashing
through my garage but anyway yeah that's
it with the with the Raspberry Pi in the
car pretty cool I'm really happy with it
so I encourage you to definitely
definitely try it out there's a lot of
other things that we can do once we have
a computer in the car as you might
imagine so I definitely I want to
upgrade this I'm not I mean this is a
cool cool application I will put a link
to it in the description but there's a
few I'd like to kind of change it up I'd
like to have like a live graph of
probably at least throttle position and
then I'd like to add a sensor to my
brake so I can get throttle and brake
position and engine rpm obviously we
want so that's kind of cool and but I'd
like to have that a little more live
than this is but this is actually still
pretty cool application but yeah so
maybe if I develop that I'll put it on
another video for that as well but for
now this is all that this will do
I hope you guys enjoyed if you have any
questions or comments maybe I forgot to
mention something feel free to leave
them in the comment section below
otherwise as always thanks for watching
thanks for all the support and
subscriptions
sorry for the bad sound I don't have my
mic out here anyway until next time